[Music]
wait wait sorry buddy I can't believe it
thank you so much for coming I haven't
seen you in years
oh I haven't seen you since eighth grade
eighth grade miss Lacy's class yes oh
he's probably flowers mm-hmm that's
awesome that's awesome but these are the
store for you you have to bring me
flowers man no crazy the way I went out
like that huh yeah well I'm in Boulder
what who'da thoughts
Boulder right I mean it's like who gets
killed by a boulder these days he says
well I mean I mean I not me I mean you
remember I was in Boulder Colorado I was
hiking and then I fell off that mountain
remember right you remember right
Boulder Colorado yeah I was hiking I
mean I know I know they couldn't find me
no I was saying like if you think about
it
Boulder killed you well not really
Boldin I mean I wouldn't say the city
per sabes they give us the Cougar that
got me and then that's what everyone was
talking about I mean I got I was out
there for like three weeks
yeah but that's neither here nor there
so hey that LinkedIn invitation I sent
you before I died ah you know I mean I
don't when I see LinkedIn I just delete
it without even checking it's totally
totally totally yeah yeah I get it I get
it
oh hey so wha what what did you want to
say to me um what do you mean you know
that's like why people come to
graveyards right is so you can say the
stuff that you wish you had said when
someone was alive right oh my god
there's so much
okay where do I start take your time man
you can lay a couple on you today and
then come back yeah I mean oh yeah I can
get it done here this is that's the
whole reason I came down here certain
you know yeah yeah it's my grandfather's
like two rows down there I was gonna
come to you say some things to you go to
him and sort of finish up oh but you
weren't coming to see me totally totally
totally well fire away man you're the
only good friend I have who's come to
visit yeah really yeah uh-huh
I just wanted to say that oh if you see
my grandfather maybe you could just tell
him that like I said you didn't come
here to visit me you came here to see
your grandfather I get it are you
talking about oops
please I'm here to see you whoa right
okay that's good school you know I I'm
just gonna you know go back to the
afterlife I'm sorry I'm being hostile
it's just a little embarrassed right now
they'll take him off-guard I'm just
gonna go go ahead take him get him ya
know go ahead get him get him
[Music]
oh just a heads up loli I'm I'm probably
gonna haunt you for the rest of your
life and if you have a daughter I'm
gonna possess the creepiest doll in her
bedroom no just say it
you